c'est le printemps le temps de l'amour
et de l'année comme un si jeune
c'est formidable c'était quelque chose
d'extraordinaire le tout c'est de
connaître formidable
oh la la
c'est formidable non si c'est formidable
et tu verras n'ont pu d'abord j'ai une
tête à ça une telle attaque pas
[Musique]
on
vous n'êtes amour
je suis toujours
vous êtes souvent en mauvais que
cherchez-vous
chez la jeune fille je peux
difficilement vous répondre parce qu'à
chaque fois je cherche quelque chose
différent
pas facile vous voulez mon avis on a
toujours un peu l'impression d'être est
seul et on cherche un peu à l'être moins
moi j'imagine l'amour un peu comme une
espèce de corde raide on essaye de se
maintenir le plus longtemps possible
si possible pour la vie des guerres mais
il faut vraiment s'attendre à tout
moment à ce que quelque chose qui fasse
tout bascule et venant soin de soi même
mais le plus souvent de quelque chose
extérieure quand j'étais jeune je disais
au jeune fille je t'aime maintenant j'ai
appris à me méfier de ce genre de
paroles définitives
ce que je suis un ajout au mieux faire
très attention donc s'engager quel âge
avez-vous 23 ans
est ce que vous vous dites je t'aime
notamment que le sous préfet
est-ce que vous pensez que l'amour
aujourd'hui rime avec toujours
pensé que l'amour est éphémère
et éphémère si on prend pas soin de
gandhi même où on trouve pratiquement
tous les panneaux est à vouloir le faire
grand bien fasse toujours en faire
quelque chose
si on le prend comme il vient si on ne
cherche pas à l'améliorer
à construire quelque chose à faire
quelque chose de constructif il
descendra comme il vient il faut vouloir
on n'a pas dire je t'aime on doit partir
ensemble
aller n'importe où mais restent ensemble
que le monde s'écroule autour de ce soir
est resté ensemble
que le reste est plus aucune importance
et que qu'est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
autour ça ne soit que pour renforcer le
français
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que les jeunes
filles ont le droit de vivre aussi
librement que les garçons n'ont pas du
tout pas du tout moi je suis assez
strict de là dessus je crois que elles
doivent garder une certaine pureté tout
en étant très gai très évolué je trouve
qu'elles doivent rester pur
c'est le résultat de votre éducation
non oui évidemment j'ai été j'ai eu
certains principes depuis mon enfance
par l'éducation que j'ai reçue mais
c'est surtout la façon dont je le pense
vraiment savais que je sais pas
sincérité c'est tout voilà vous êtes
contre l'égalité absolument contre
est ce que vous attendez la pureté
physique de votre femme
j'ai bien ri jc et les hommes sont un
peu d'ailleurs à gori de smallville a
pas ce qu'ils attendent souvent du moins
pureté physique la femme mais ils sont
pas mine en tant que célibataires ils
ont rien fait pour ça en fait d'attendre
même comment vous appelez-vous oui oui
laisse les grecs vous êtes américaine
oui quel âge avez vous 21 et vous je
m'appelle girard j'ai 22 ans que
faites-vous puis étudiant en lettres et
que fait les libyens aux etats-unis elle
était chanteuse et actrice est en ce
moment à la banque française
pourquoi est elle venue en france
faudrait peut-être nous demander
et tracteurs
pour l'être avec
gérard oury
vous l'aimez
et vous voulez mais harry
vous vivez ensemble oui
pourquoi ne déposez vous pas
parce que ça ne me paraît pas une
nécessité de commencer quelque chose
pour le mariage l'amour ce n'est pas le
mariage surtout le mariage ce n'est pas
l'amour je ne suis pas contre le mariage
pour l'instant ça ne me paraît pas une
nécessité
mariage se présentant pour moi comme
une sorte de règle une sorte de
normalisation sur tout élément la
société si vous voulez qui vous permet
d'entrer dans un système mais ça ne veut
pas dire que ça vous permet d'entrer
dans l'amour on dit que les gars en
profitent des félibres et finissent par
la cause et les autres nous ont dit
beaucoup de choses
ça dépend si vous aimez quelqu'un vous
êtes vous resté avec cette personne si
elle est nécessaire c'est vous paraît si
vous bâtissez votre monde autour d'elle
vous n'avez pas besoin d'aller autre
part pourquoi les paquets quand même des
filles qu'on ait posé pour les autres
cependant il ya des filles qu'on aime
défi qu'on dit mais qu'est ce qu'il vous
plaît en elle
sa douceur sa beauté au départ c'était
cela stilic mans superficielle physique
et depuis que je connais mieux
j'apprends apprécier ses qualités
morales
quel est votre idéal de faire
mon idéal c'est un complexe il faudrait
une sorte de baby doll de femme enfant
mais qui serait en même temps
profonde intelligente je crois que c'est
assez difficile à trouver sortirait
confirme ça correspond
pas tout à fait personne ne peut
correspond tout à fait à l'idéal
enfin je crois que son approche assez et
qu'est ce qui vous plaît en lui moi
j'apprécie énormément c'est envers sa
sincérité jeu qu'on sera très dur et
tendre
donne vraiment l'impression de quelqu'un
qu'on a envie de protéger a dit qu'il
voulait mais
je ne sais pas j'ai pas encore j'ai pas
encore tellement fait que ces mêmes
j'ai besoin de progrès beaucoup de temps
masse je ne sais pas si certains
enfin je
est-ce que vous l'aimez oui
peut aimer plusieurs fois dans ma vie
mais tes chances manière
c'est bien surtout quand les jeunes va
recevoir impression d mais elle et ça
dure pas longtemps et puis vers le haut
en compte la mort avec un moral
peut-être pas toute la vie parce que ça
doit être très rare je pense enfin pas
vraiment partie de l'espace quand même
[Musique]